good morning John I wish that I had
turned on the camera like five minutes
ago when this happened but I was just
playing twenty qnet and I was playing
and it asked me all kinds of questions
and I was laughing about how they
applied to you or didn't apply to you
it's so funny was he popular in the
1980s and I'm like know who he was not
popular in the 1980s and it was like
does he wear makeup and I was like no
but obviously kind of hot in
Indianapolis he's kind of shiny and it
kept asking if you like played sports or
used a ball or we're right-handed or
played in the NFL I was like this thing
is so op it's like two billion percent
off and then it guessed you were Neil
Armstrong bong and then I guess rodney
mullen and I'm like who's rodney mullen
and it asked if you were young and I
hovered back and forth not really sure
not old but young so I said yes you were
young and then it said I'm guessing John
Green author 20q damn you are good as
far as I'm concerned this is the
definition of famous John you are now
officially famous 20q got you and 22
questions it popped up John Green author
and I was like huh this is definitely
nerdfighters doing I'm not under any
illusions but amazing high five
okay I just check that it got the answer
right and it said are you sure John
Green is part of a team other users clip
that he wasn't part of a team hey now
what is this you don't think that this
is a team so yeah I thought I was Perez
Hilton I thought you were Neil Armstrong
and then it actually got you I'm gonna
look up who rodney mullen is and see if
that guy's embarrassing good dude damn G
rodney mullen is like a super awesome
skateboarder like in Perez Hilton this
is getting worse and worse I just played
as me and it thinks from Joe Jonas oh
god what is it about this also it occurs
to me the Neil Armstrong also part of
the team poor Michael Collins I mean at
least people know who buzz
cauldron is but nobody even knows who
Michael Collins is and he didn't even
get to walk on the moon Oh Mike Mike
Mike Mike I'm sure you're doing fine I'm
not worried about you or anything but
you know just just say hey how's it
going out there guys everything looking
cool and yeah you playing golf that
sounds like fun
okay okay I'm gonna try it 20q Mike
Collins and see if it gets Mike question
17 22 makes its first guess are you Neil
Armstrong question 20 I am guessing that
you are Buzz Aldrin I mean this must be
Mike's entire life just summed up in a
round of 20 cue though I don't think I
can really blame 20q for this because at
the end it was like other people said
that you died an untimely death is not
that maybe I haven't heard very much
about him lately
Mike this one's for you I don't know
what this one is this one or this one or
this one or this one
I got a mom Mike they're all for you
moral of the story is I shouldn't be
upset if 20q doesn't know who I am I
haven't even been to the moon but
congratulations John you are officially
more famous than the dude who went to
the moon but didn't get out of the boat
so obviously you kick-ass thank you for
being my brother and you don't see me
tomorrow